[Music]
[Music]
good evening I'd like to welcome you to
the fourth in the series of the Ford MIT
Nobel laureate lectures and we would
like to thank Ford Motor Company for
their sponsorship of this series tonight
speaker is Professor David Baltimore
president of California Institute of
Technology professor Baltimore is not a
stranger to MIT he was a professor of
biology in the Cancer Center at MIT for
many years and was the founding director
of the Whitehead Institute for
biomedical research at MIT and in that
capacity and in other capacities as
president of Caltech he has made great
contributions both to biological
research and to national science policy
in fact he told me he still has a lab at
Caltech
dr. Baltimore helped to pioneer the
molecular study of animal viruses and
his research has been has had profound
implications for understanding cancer
and AIDS he was awarded the Nobel Prize
in 1975 for his work in virology
specifically for the interaction between
tumor viruses and the genetic material
of the cell
dr. Baltimore has been a major figure in
the u.s. as head of the NIH AIDS vaccine
research committee he was awarded the
1999 Medal of Science and recognition of
his research achievements his excellence
in building scientific institutions and
his ability to foster communication
between scientists and the public I'd
like to also remind you there will be a
reception after the lecture in the lobby
his talk tonight is entitled building a
community on trust Dave
[Applause]
thanks Bob it's a great pleasure to have
the opportunity back at MIT to be back
in Kresge Auditorium one of the great
venues in the world and to see many new
many old friends particularly happy that
dr. Zeller Lauria came here tonight and
I thank her her husband Salvador Luria
as many of you will know played a
central role in my life played a central
role in the life of MIT and was himself
a Nobel laureate when I was asked to do
this I faced a difficult choice because
although I have ascended some might say
descended to the role of president of a
university I still find it easiest to
discuss molecular biology it's second
easiest to discuss Caltech because those
are things that I know very well but
neither of them seemed right for this
occasion Chuck vest and Bob Silva had
certainly not invited me because they
wanted to learn about transcription
factors or about signal transduction in
the immune system I think they were
looking for something with a wider
interest and I don't think they wanted
my fundraising pitch for Caltech so in
this period of talking about something
that I personally know well I thought I
would take on a topic that has been a
concern of mine for a very long time
which is the critical role of trust in
human relations and I Haitian to assure
you that I know that this is turf on
which I am crazy to tread trust is at
the heart of philosophical theories
about human motivation about which my
own knowledge is minimal so I approached
this as an amateur trust is a central
part of our lives but an ephemeral guns
it is like the golden rule you can trust
me if I reciprocate and then we have an
effective relationship and community but
Trust has been falling out of fashion
with the methods of surveillance we have
today with the power of computers to
detect fraud it might seem that we can
enforce moral behavior we can put our
trust in our methods of control not in
people but I think September 11th and
the Enron scandal have raised serious
doubts about our ability to use
technology to assure transparency and
moral behavior as far as I can see Trust
is more important than ever because
technology may help in monitoring
behavior but it also provides the tools
for observation that's the hardest word
the English language to say chicanery
and downright fraud two of the a
formative events in my life took place
at MIT and both centrally involved trust
the first was the formation of the
Whitehead Institute which is now 20
years ago and for those of you who do
not remember let me remind you that when
Jack White had offered to fund this
Institute with a hundred and thirty five
million dollars of his own money the
response was not joy but suspicion it
was fueled from various fronts including
the Boston Globe and certain members of
the MIT faculty and I had been tapped by
Jack to try to build this institute but
he wasn't particularly committed to MIT
as its host it was I who desperately
wanted to be here and so there ensued a
year of negotiation when I tried
ultimately successfully to convince the
MIT community that Jack the Whitehead
was not trying to hijack its essence to
his own ends but rather was trying to
build an institution
that would add to the intellectual power
of MIT we crafted an affiliation
agreement that governs the relationship
between these two institutions to this
day but we all knew that no piece of
paper could define all of the
interactions there had to be trust the
year was actually spent developing that
trust
I remember the final faculty meeting
where the relationship was cemented and
the argument that carried the day was
that MIT was built by Taking Chances
meaning that we had only developed the
minimum level of trust necessary and it
took years more before it was evident
that Whitehead the Whitehead Institute
wanted nothing more than to be a
productive member of this community the
other formative event was the affair of
Teresa mone Shikari this evolved over
ten years and has been chronicled in
books and so I will not attempt to recap
it here
however at its heart was the trust
necessary to carry out collaborative
scientific work as I will say later I
think this is a fundamental aspect of
the scientific enterprise especially
today as science is becoming more
interdisciplinary that she was
ultimately vindicated in her assertion
of the rectitude of her behavior showed
that my trust in her was well placed
however it underlined a critical aspect
of any collaborative activity which is
that both sides have to satisfy
themselves that their trust is justified
it's a tricky business because it
involves recognizing that a bit of
suspicion is appropriate even while the
relationship must be a trusting one a
friend of mine who writes about how
organizations function puts trust at the
center of his analysis but he says that
trust is something you have to give upon
entering a relationship with another
person in science it is true that we
assume
colleague is trustworthy and only an
extremist do we doubt his or her honesty
while a colleague whom we may never have
met when such a colleague comes to give
a seminar we don't ask that the
colleague prove his or her veracity we
assume that but in a collaboration where
both parties will ultimately have to
vouch for the integrity of the results
testing the trustworthiness of a
collaborator generally in subtle ways
seems a good idea these days I continue
to direct a laboratory as was just
mentioned but I have limited time as you
might imagine to spend with my trainees
therefore I just have to have a deep
trust in them for instance we just
published a paper describing a new
method of making transgenic mice which
is an unusual area of investigation for
me to be involved in on the other hand I
had no reason to doubt the findings it's
after all hard to fabricate a green
mouse or rat which is what we made but I
was glad that there were a few people
working closely together on this project
and actually you know it's it is really
rare to come across fraud in science
many postdocs and graduate students with
whom I've worked have been searingly
honest checking on the other hand is not
a poor idea in world affairs Trust is
not in vogue today it's it's it's
antithesis is war and we are living with
war rather than the open and trusting
society we had not long ago we now have
airport guards screening our shoes
border guards screening us at every
portal of entry to the country and an
Olympics of FBI agents we are grateful
for the protection because we have been
shown that the world harbors enemies who
will use trust as a shield to gain entry
to our country to our facilities and to
our transportation systems
the wonderful thing about the academic
world is the trust remains a foundation
of all of our activities it goes beyond
the trust of colleagues that is the
foundation of any intellectual community
an important part of the academic
process involves the trust that students
place in their teachers I'm sure we all
remember the terrible case of Joseph
Ellis the Mount Holyoke historian who
invented his tour in Vietnam presumably
to present himself in a more exciting
light to his students when it became
known that he had never had the
experiences he recounted the whole
academic community was horrified he had
not lied in his teaching or his
scholarship but even in just lying about
himself he had broken the trust that
students have for their teachers honesty
in the relationship of students and
teachers is rarely questioned with trust
freely given and the rarity of cases
like that of Ellis justifies that trust
another component of the trust of
academia is the trust that parents give
that their offspring will be treated
with care and respect when they send
them into the academic world Caltech and
MIT get a very similar sort of student
and they're often headstrong and
difficult to manage but they are our
responsibility and living up to the
trust placed in us is a challenge we
cannot shirk trust plays a very special
role at Caltech because both
undergraduate and graduate student life
is built around an honor system
the on ursus code of Caltech states that
quote no member shall take unfair
advantage of any member of the Caltech
community it's an awkward phrase but it
works as our catalog says it is more
than merely a code applying to conduct
in examinations it extends to all phases
of campus life it is the code for back
havior governing scholastic and
extracurricular activities relations
among students and relations between
students and faculty its adjudicated by
a Board of Control made up by students
is it perfect no but we in the Cal State
community live the honor code by giving
all our examinations as take-home exams
to be governed by whatever the
particular set of rules that were laid
but down by the examiner open book
versus closed book time for completion
of the exam etc now I suppose there is a
little cheating but basically it works
and alumni say that the honor code is
the most important lesson of a Caltech
education because it sets a standard for
their behavior for the rest of their
lives they have seen a community based
on trust and on personal integrity and
they know the value of trust in creating
a community of interests Trust does
break down in the academic world when
there's misrepresentation plagiarism or
fraud and many of us can remember that
in the early 1990s this was a big issue
because politicians were arguing that
fraud was rampant in science and the
press picked up the issue that climate
was at the heart of the personal events
I lived through the suspicion of the
rectitude of scientists has quieted down
at least partly because the community
put in place procedures for dealing with
allegations of fraud my belief is that
it was never a big problem the probably
the rate of incidents has neither
increase nor decrease but that the
visibility of the problem has dropped
away it is interesting that today not
science but history is the field where
both plagiarism and personal
misrepresentation have been major issues
personal integrity is crucial in the
field of history because the historian
is always making choices about what
facts to emphasize
and is often interpreting the
motivations of historic figures it's
important to remember that science too
has a subjective component that
scientists select data to present
science may be more objective than
history but all intellectual endeavor
depends on personal integrity trust
plays different roles in different types
of science a single investigator working
on a problem can do personal science
requiring trust in no other individual
however so much science today is group
science where many people contribute to
a single result and group science
depends on trust this dependence becomes
magnified as the number of interacting
people increases in projects that
qualify as big science hundreds of
scientists may collaborate actually the
word science subsumes many different
kinds of investigations a simple cat
occur as a categorization might
distinguish three types of scientific
investigation observational research
hypothesis driven research and
technology development let's look at
them individually observational science
is the modern incarnation of the chief
mode of studying the world in early
times primitive people looked around saw
the world given them and began to
catalogue it they named the plants and
animals they named the constellations
they made hypotheses about how the world
came about which then became enshrined
in myth or religion but rather than
testing such ideas they accepted them
and allowed them to shape their
worldview today instead of these kinds
of observations we observe molecular
structures we observe gene structures we
observe protein protein interactions we
still do a lot of science with the goal
of describing the world but at finer and
finer scales of resolution
our accelerators and our observatories
are often designed to answer particular
questions but the rationale for their
construction is also to extend the
catalogue of observations to new
energies of interaction for instance or
to new depths of the universe
observational science today is done on a
very large scale for biologists who have
long looked into microscopes and gasped
at the intricacy of nature the scale of
today's observational science represents
a qualitatively new mode of
Investigation the most massive
enterprise of course is the genome
project which is giving us catalogues of
information about the genetic
inheritance of many organisms of this
earth it involves the work of hundreds
of scientists all of whom must trust
each other at Caltech we are involved in
one of the great projects of 20th
century 21st century observation we're
part of a consortium making a virtual
observatory that will link the
observations of the sky made at all
different wavelengths by different
instruments in one terrifyingly huge but
widely distributed database when it is
complete you will be able to pick a spot
on the sky and get all of the
information available about that spot in
an orchestrated search of many
individual databases held in
institutions around the world it will
include data at visible infrared
ultraviolet radio and x-ray frequencies
from recent work at Caltech and
elsewhere we may even include the
microwave background variation giving
evidence of what that region of sky
looked like in the years just following
the Big Bang I should add that Caltech
and MIT are jointly involved in creating
one of the most imaginative new
observatories LIGO the laser
interferometry gravitational wave
observatory this will look for a new
form of radiation gravity waves that
have yet to be seen
but have been firmly predicted by
Einstein as a consequence of relativity
firmly means everybody believes they
will be seeing information from LIGO
will ultimately become part of the
virtual observatory but for the moment
we're just hoping to see a signal of
some sort when it starts collecting data
next year there are many theories
predicting results results but since no
one's ever seen the evidence of a
gravity wave this is the ultimate form
of observational science we're just
making an observation of any sort will
be considered a huge victory
the trouble with big science is also its
great strength
it involves many people working together
towards a particular end in a
collaborative enterprise in which the
contribution of the individual is often
obscured furthermore it often removes
from consideration
one of the chief motivations for
becoming involved in science the ability
for an individual to choose the
questions he or she wishes to work on
actually when students come to me and
ask what the difference is between
University based science and corporate
science I think that's the main
difference to point to the ability in
academia when you're your own boss to do
anything you wish were the only
limitation being finding the money to do
it in companies
you're usually constrained to work on
just those problems that contribute to
corporate goals for instance early on in
the development are actually by contrast
early on in the development of
biotechnology company scientists had a
lot of freedom but that freedom has been
severely restricted because the industry
is maturing so big academic science and
corporate science have homologies and
one thing is for certain if you want to
develop your own individuality in
science
you're better off working in a small
science framework big science projects
are not good venues for training the
next generation of scientists
I suggested before there are three modes
of science the second hypothesis driven
science is often done in a small-scale
mode by an investigator working closely
with a small group but high-energy
physics the quintessential big science
is generally hypothesis driven in
biology the hypotheses may come from
prior observational science from an
earlier hypothesis driven experiment or
even occasionally from theory in
high-energy physics theories often the
driver interestingly astronomers use
enormous observatories that are run by
dedicated staffs and that are very
expensive to maintain
but whether they're developing
catalogues of celestial elements or are
testing particular ideas they work in a
classic small science mode with a single
investigator making observations today
that investigator is no longer in a
freezing-cold chamber open to the sky
but in a cosy computer room often a
significant remove from the chilled
mirror collecting the light the third
mode of science I differentiated before
is one that is rarely emphasized
technology development is often
considered to be engineering and
separated from science but when I came
to Caltech one of the discoveries I made
about my job was that I was responsible
for operating the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory there 5,000 people labor to
produce spacecraft that either orbit the
earth or that go out into the solar
system these spacecraft are designed to
do science the Hubble telescope is the
most notable of such spacecraft but
there are lots of others working at
other wavelengths in looking at other
phenomena there are spacecraft observing
in Mars there are one circling the earth
looking for meteorological events for
instance El Nino and there's even one up
there collecting the particles of the
solar wind
to return them to earth so we can
understand what the what the Sun is made
of these spacecraft are all doing
science so their design and manufacture
is a central part of the scientific
enterprise in the 1980s LaHood than a
professor at Caltech had the idea that
technology could advance biology much as
technology was at the center of space
science so he developed a group to build
hardware and their most notable
achievement was the automated DNA
sequencer again science was the goal the
abilities sequence large amounts of DNA
but technology development was the
activity that they pursued and the Human
Genome Project which depended entirely
on having automated sequencing was the
proof of how right hood was to
concentrate on this then very
unfashionable element of biological
science for spacecraft technology
development involves very high end
engineering because of the unique
constraints of working in space the most
obvious of these constraints is the cost
of a single satellite which ranges from
a few hundred million dollars to a
billion or more dollars with that kind
of investment in just one instrument it
has to be built to very high tolerances
to minimize the plot to minimize the
possibility of failure because of the
enormous propulsive forces that are
needed to leave the Earth's atmosphere
or even to get into orbit around the
earth another constraint is weight with
a huge premium put on miniaturization
finally power availability on the
spacecraft is a key constraint making
low-power instruments a necessity
thus literally thousands of people's
work may be embodied in a single
satellite do they all trust each other
actually well they have certain well
certainly are interdependent in their
activities they have developed
engineering systems that check on the
functioning of each component they put
each satellite through a battery of
tests often subjecting it condition to
conditions
thought to be much harsher than those
that they would encounter when it flies
in in space this is not because of a
lack of trust but because at that level
of complexity Trust is simply not
sufficient you have to be sure one
reason why spacecraft are so
phenomenally expensive is because of the
need to monitor each step and to test
continually this was proven in the
mid-1990s you may remember that the then
NASA Administrator Dan Goldin
introduced the mantra of faster better
cheaper he wanted more satellites and at
a lower cost per mission well the
consequence was that two probes sent to
Mars failed each because of a very minor
error in one a conversion from English
to metric units was missed in the other
a software loop was missed the
consequences for the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory were catastrophic each was a
tiny error 99 plus percent of the
technology worked perfectly the lesson
we learned was that you could not skimp
on testing because in both cases the
kind of extensive testing that had
previously been done was skipped in
order to satisfy a straight-in budget an
expensive lesson but one that has been
learned so in some kinds of highly
interdisciplinary science trust is
simply not enough not because of
conscious error but because of the
catastrophic effects of even inadvertent
error but most interdisciplinary science
is not so demanding of perfection it
involves a few people bringing
complementary skills to a project but
because each has a separate skill they
cannot easily check on each other
and one generally has to accept the work
of another as being reliable thus the
push to interdisciplinary science which
is evident today throughout the academic
world particularly when you when
studying questions that are posed in
biology that kind of an
interdisciplinary work requires a high
degree of trust let me spend a moment on
the importance of interdisciplinary work
in biology what our particularly
generative of interdisciplinary
approaches are the massive observational
experiments that are underway the first
of these was the sequencing of genomes
which required the skills of
mathematicians computer scientists
engineers geneticists and scientific
entrepreneurs to generate and handle the
huge volume of data but now having the
genome as a resource
these same complementary strengths are
being applied to screening operations
that are designed to ferret out
regularities that will be suggestive of
underlying biology and there's much more
to interdisciplinary activities in
biology for instance there's extensive
work on new imaging systems that bring
physicists and chemists together with
biologists there are efforts to use the
brain to control prostheses that Mel the
skills of robot assists with
neurophysiologists there are efforts at
miniatures ation of screening methods
that bring applied physicists and
engineers together with biochemists one
of the key reasons that trust is more
critical than ever in science is that we
have powerful new tools that can be used
for data manipulation Photoshop is a
paradigm here a program that can react
create an artificial reality it is
interesting how easily we accept the
manipulation of reality today when for
instance we go to the movies in a sense
it is the ultimate realization that
photography is an art not a chronicle of
reality when manray went into the
darkroom and created his ray of
in the 1920s the art world was shocked
that photography could be a medium in
which one painted abstraction z'
directly on film today we accept with
equanimity computer-generated images as
part of the artistic process whether in
still images or in movies basically we
suspend trust when we enter the realm of
art and consciously put ourselves in the
hands of the artist this contrasts
completely with a scientific world where
we trust implicitly implicitly that
reality has been preserved and not
created the problem is that the tools
are so powerful and so pervasive that
much data is selected digitally analyzed
and possibly enhanced or modified for
effectiveness of presentation this
underscores the need for trust and of
course puts an onus on the investigator
to be transparent about the relation of
the presented data to the original in
the larger world Trust is a key to
commerce recently the Enron scandal has
emphasized how completely investment is
a matter of trust
Enron was able to hide from scrutiny its
financial manipulations but people
invested anyway taking at face value
whatever information was presented by
the company Trust is particularly not
invoked today in the investment world
because so many people got burned by
Enron and by other companies that
obscured their reality I've been
involved for years in biotechnology
investment and I know firsthand how
difficult it is to get reliable
information about any company one tries
to minimize the need for trust but
without becoming an insider and thus
greatly limiting your freedom as an
investor you cannot get much information
about the inner workings of a company
because Trust is an inevitable part of
any investment decision the personal
integrity of the management of a company
becomes a key element in a
for instance one of the darlings of
biotechnology recently has been a
company called M clone a company that
has developed a very promising
anti-cancer drug of course validation of
the effectiveness of a drug like this
must be done by the FDA the Food and
Drug Administration if the drug is to
get on the market and therefore it's
critically important to an investor to
have an honest picture of the
interactions between the company and the
FDA
however the investment world knew about
M clone that there had key personnel in
their management with less than a
pristine background the difficulty is
that if one simply said we won't invest
in a company unless management can be
trusted implicitly we would have missed
one of the best run ups in the
biotechnology market in history so the
investment people I work with took the
chance the stock did appreciate but then
it emerged that the management and
apparently not been honest about their
communication with the FDA and we had
lots of others got burned life provides
opportunities for big changes life
sometimes precipitates our into
situations for which our backgrounds
haven't even prepared us the biggest to
me was going from managing a laboratory
at MIT to managing first the Whitehead
Institute and then two universities
Rockefeller University and now Caltech
the movement from the laboratory to the
directors or president's office is a
huge one because you go from directing a
unit where you have a long-term
familiarity with the working parts to
one where there are many elements that
are at best vaguely comprehensible like
the HVAC system or the payroll system or
athletics or the mathematicians
the latter are particularly
incomprehensible so I'm now in a
position of running an almost two
billion dollar operation when you
include JPL and what you discover
quickly when you take on such an
enterprise is that you are deeply
dependent on each other to make it go
each vice-president each head of a
department or a division or even each
head of a laboratory has to be someone
in whom you can place your trust not
just that they will be ethical but that
they will be diligent and effective in
their jobs another part of my life is
that about two years ago I became a
director of Amgen the world's largest
biotechnology company shortly after I
joined the board we got a new CEO and so
I've had a chance to watch how he has
chosen to manage this four billion
dollar enterprise one piece of it was
remarkably simple he puts an
extraordinary amount of his energy into
the people of Amgen he evaluates them he
promotes them he interacts with them he
organizes them occasionally he even has
determinated but he's constantly gauging
whether or not they continue to deserve
his trust he was trained at General
Electric where if I understand correctly
this style of management was honed he's
taught me a lot about how to manage a
large institution it's the people stupid
in thinking about the role of trust in
our lives I must point to our personal
lives even in our most intimate
relationships with our children and our
partners Trust is crucial and a
breakdown of trust paves the pathway to
disaster the development of the moral
sense of children is an illuminating
topic because a parent is always
wondering when children have reached the
age or the stage when they can be
trusted my 27 year old daughter tells me
now how she would sneak out at night
when she was an early teenager growing
up in Cambridge I didn't trust her to be
out but she believed she deserved the
trust and took matters into her own
in retrospect I guess she was right at
least she lived through the experiences
to become an adult let me digress for a
moment and consider a more general issue
Trust is an interpersonal interaction
one of a myriad of interactions that
make up a society some of these are
rational many are unexamined however it
is evident that we're entering a period
of scientific investigation of
interpersonal interactions that this is
going to have profound implications
particularly for the social sciences now
like most hard scientists I grew up some
people don't think biology is a hard
science but I do I grew up with a belief
that the social sciences had
appropriated the title of science but
were unable to provide the output of
understanding that at least I expected
of a science in spite of the often
rigorous use of scientific methodology
especially in psychology the insights
were at best good stories even economics
for all of its use of mathematics was
unable to explain how human beings make
economic choices my mother actually was
one of the last of the gestalt
psychologists they were a remarkable
group of thinkers who tried very hard to
develop a mechanistic base for Purse of
perception but they had to fail at this
because they simply did not know enough
about the brain to understand how the
brain perceives the outside world the
big change today is that we're learning
about where in the brain decisions are
made and we can expect over the next
decade to learn how decisions are made
in spite of its limited resolution with
magnetic magnetic resonance imaging
we're able to watch the brains of people
and also the brains of monkeys as they
make decisions this is the beginning of
a social science that can explain
behavior and Caltech our social
scientists are working now closely we
systems neuroscientists to begin to
generate a science of social
interactions economists political
scientists and psychologists are
designing experimental systems where
humans make choices and are beginning to
see how the brain handles this kind of
problem even our professor of finance
has now totally consumed by the ideas
the idea that he can test theories of
financial behavior it all evolved from a
school of research called experimental
economics in which economists pose
problems to groups of people
often in auction or market emulations
and then they see how people behave and
how they interact
it's a classic mode of testing a theory
experimentally and it often shows that
the theory needs adjustment moving these
experiments into the MRI machine as a
way of moving into the black box where
the decisions actually occur what it is
sure to show is how emotion interacts
with rationality this type of thinking
is becoming pervasive in the arts and
humanities as well as in the social
sciences there are now people trying to
understand how artistic appreciation is
registered in the brain actually they're
making more progress than the social
scientists because their issue is easier
since it involves only subjective
experience and not injured personal
interaction meanwhile at Caltech our
philosophers are becoming interested in
how the brain works
while our neuroscientists are becoming
interested in consciousness a confluence
of investigation that I think has
revolutionary possibilities I thought I
would tell you a little bit about one of
the most interesting people working at
this intersection of experiment and
social science at Caltech Jean Ensminger
a cultural anthropologist whom we hired
recently she came only last year after
years that we had spent searching for an
anthropologist whom it made sense
to have that Caltech where we have this
very experimentally oriented social
science group and actually if any of you
read The Wall Street Journal you might
have read about her work a month or so
ago when they featured it what she and a
small band of others have been doing is
experiments to understand the choice
behavior of people in different types of
societies Jean had worked in a village
in rural Kenya so she started there and
the experiment she did had to be very
simple because this is a preliterate
population so it was about as simple as
you can get give a person some money
about a day's wage and they actually use
real money and asked them to share it
with another person both of them know
the amount of money involved and if the
second person does not accept the gift
then neither gets anything but if the
gift is accepted both keep their money
so say player one gets $10 and offers
one dollar player two may feel that
player one is being stingy and out of a
sense of fairness refused the offer
effectively punishing player one by
giving up the one dollar but if player
one offers $5 then player two is likely
to accept and both will be five dollars
richer now do this experiment in a
subsistence community in Kenya in a
small town in Missouri in a
hunter-gatherer community in Tanzania in
fact in some fifteen different settings
what you come up with tells a lot about
how societies work and how individuals
approach each other in the least
developed communities the players won
offer the least percentage of their
money in an American setting they offer
close to a 50/50 split a conclusion is
that being in a market society leads to
fairness if not altruism
what would Karl Marx think of that
outcome
Sam Bowles who was involved in such work
says quote many people thought markets
would make people selfish in a moral
that view is at least two simple if not
just plain wrong
Jean ends mayor says the most altruistic
and trusting societies are those that
are the most market oriented and another
commentator said that assumptions about
trust are built into a market economy
contrast these conclusions within
conclusions that the Enron scandal
suggests Enron used the trust that we
have in markets to convince of
investigators that they should put their
money in Enron stock to have doubted
their veracity took a deeply suspicious
analyst but trusting is the necessary
response of people in a market economy
because without trust the market could
not exist
the alternative to trust would be
perfect knowledge and there's no way to
get that in fact as I noted earlier if
you do have a deep knowledge of a
company then you become an Insider this
experiment that I described and other
experiments like it are putting some
meat on the bones of concepts like trust
they define such vague concepts in an
experimental setting making them
operational terms like the many others
that are used in science for instance
other investigators have been looking at
what people do when they act
cooperatively this has generated the
unlikely concept of altruistic
punishment members of a group will
punish those in the group for not acting
reasonably even if the Punisher gains
nothing by the punishment I've been
skeptical of what has been a controlling
notion in biology that is the notion of
The Selfish Gene it's a notion which
derived from the belief that a person
will act toward another person in
altruistic ways if that other person is
a blood relative and the idea is that
we act to favor our own genes because
the genes are driving us to that
behavior I see these experimental
economics results raising a very
different paradigm and one that strikes
me is more meaningful there perhaps not
contradictory but I wonder whether the
selfish gene will ultimately succumb to
notions of trust and cooperation among
relatives this talk has been an unusual
one for me to give it came about because
I found myself so often facing the issue
of trust in my dealings with the world I
hope that I have made all of you just a
little more aware of this central
element of human relations at the same
time I hope I've raised the question of
whether such a fundamental concept of
trust may not soon be a subject of
scientific study as a university
president I find myself thinking about
the directions of scientific
investigation and I think I see that an
important direction is the serious
encroachment of scientific thinking into
provinces where it previously could not
be applied I find this exciting
especially if it leads to more effective
human into relations and I thank you all
very much for your attention
Thank You professor Baltimore and he's
agreed to answer take questions from the
audience and I think there were some
microphones around and we can have
people come up somebody Thank You
professor Baltimore I would like to get
your opinion regarding altruism amongst
one's relatives I'm a recent postdoc and
I feel that perhaps the greatest
erosional force that I worry about
contributing to the demise of trust
within the sciences derives not from the
fear of incorrect or even fictitious
data but rather relates to communicating
valid findings and is derivative of the
incredible pressure put upon researchers
by competition for recognition
publication priority and funding in
short it seems that nothing is to be
trusted to one's colleagues nothing is
to be shared until it is published or at
the very least in press and a journal
with a very rapid turnaround time do you
have any comments about what we as a
scientific community can do to stem to
stem this time it's a very difficult
question I recognize that it is and it
is difficult because of the very strong
competition that exists among scientific
groups today something which is easy to
rule but very hard to do anything about
when I grew up in science over the last
40 years
it was the ethic of the times to talk
about anything you were doing published
or not and I remember being very noid
with a few scientists who never seem to
talk about anything but
published data or data very soon to be
published because why go to a talk if
you can read it you go to a talk to try
to get either a different kind of
synthesis or to get more more
contemporary and maybe less certain
information and I agree it's harder to
get that today it's harder to find
people who are willing to to talk about
what they're doing rather than what
they've already done to talk about
things which are a little less certain
rather than the things that they've
already put their stamp on and put in to
pretend to print and it is partly maybe
even largely a matter of not wanting the
quote competition to know what's going
on it's a sad commentary on science when
it reaches that point because we
presumably grew up with the notion that
science is a collaborative activity and
the competition although sort of
necessary and humanly understandable
shouldn't be the driving force but I'm
afraid with the amounts the number of
scientists involved for instance in the
biological sciences which I know best
it's very hard to maintain the kind of
civility that you'd like to maintain so
I think we lose something from the size
and actually effectiveness of our
community of scientists in incivility
and I don't know how to change it
except to behave differently and to try
to prove to people that you can be
effective and still be open and I
believe that's correct but I can tell
you that today when I go to the people
in my lab and say I'd like to talk about
the work you're doing it as a meeting
and they say well wait let's wait until
it's published or late to wait until
it's written up and I understand why
they're saying it but it certainly
doesn't make me happy so I haven't I
haven't
but I've agreed with you and maybe to
great lengths yes in the early eighties
there was fairly substantial faculty
controversy over the founding of the
Whitehead a connected but autonomous
institution could you comment on the
Whitehead as a case study of the role of
trust in building such an unusual and
yet overtime tremendously successful
organization yes I can I think the
reason that the Y tends to work that I
was talking with some people about it
earlier today worked so well was that my
interest was in building an institution
that would last and an institution that
lasts can't be focused on an individual
it has to be focused on a process which
guarantees its continued excellence and
I think it was putting in place that
process through the affiliation
agreement that we had with it with MIT
as well as through the way we worked it
out in practice because you can never
imagine everything that's going to
happen
I think that's was that that's what made
it work and so I'm a great believer that
you that you have to put in place
processes which are the underlying
strength of institutions and what Wyden
shows is that those processes can be
evolved very rapidly they don't have to
be inherited from your forefathers you
don't have to be Harvard University to
have processes in place which can
guarantee the strength of an institution
I don't know exactly when but at some
time in the future it should be possible
for perhaps a single graduate student or
a postdoc to create you know University
laboratory some kind of pathogen that if
let loose
might cause very grave harm kill very
many people or worse and I'm wondering
right now we can sort of trust that
maybe that's not happening and I'm
wondering what can we do in the future
that's a that's a good question because
I think you've put it in the right
context today we are not yet to the
point where we have to worry about it
terribly what we're in fact discovering
is the pathogenesis is a very
complicated concept and involves the
interaction of lots of different
components and so it's not easy to
modify it and to make things worse but
we'll understand it well enough and
we'll figure out how to do it and in
fact in some very simplistic ways the
Russians may have actually been trying
to do that in in the 80s but I think
what's going on now which is to try to
register the laboratories that are
involved in work with pathogens and to
keep some kind of surveillance of what's
going on maybe a necessary thing doesn't
make me happy but on the other hand I
think we really do have to watch out and
your note your suggestion was that a
single individual working on on their
own in a laboratory might be sufficient
to do this and that the implication is
that nobody around would know what
they're doing so the second thing is
openness about what people are doing
most dangerous thing is secrecy now I
really believe that we're better off in
dealing with pathogens and whatever to
have openness about what's being done
rather than secrecy previously we had
secrecy biological warfare was done
behind barriers of secrecy nobody knew
what was going on it turns out not a lot
was going on but no one knew what it was
today we have we have openness
biological warfare research in principle
but our government today is moving to
increased secrecy you can see in the
headlines in the papers every day and
that could put us right back where we
were but with much power more powerful
tools tools of recombinant DNA research
that will allow us to allow in principle
the production of more pathogenic
organisms I will remind you that the
anthrax that we saw being distributed
through the mails probably came from a
laboratory we don't really know where it
came from but probably came from a
fairly expert manufacturer yes New York
Times front page today top right corner
headline the Pentagon wants to start an
office or is mitting admitting to
starting an office to this enormous or
fabricate information to motivate people
support inside and outside the US for
their war on terrorism or they call it
is this a loss of naivete on the side of
the public because obviously if I was
the Pentagon I would try to do that why
are they stating that obviously to
everyone do they want to make it
legitimate do they is it do they want to
create a climate where things like that
are more tolerated at the same time they
want more observation more technology to
observe for people are doing what is
going on I mean right I'm shocked the
Pentagon is putting out disinformation
I agree with you completely in the
implication your question that is who
should be surprised that they're doing
it no one it's been done for years every
organization puts out disinformation and
run to the fore and why was there an
article I think because a couple of
hotshot reporters suddenly had evidence
that it was happening and wrote an
article about it
I was not at all surprised to discover
that was going on and well it doesn't
make me
happy to know that that the Pentagon's
try to manipulate the press particularly
foreign press but I am no I'm not
surprised Trust sometimes well more
often than not being a delicate issue of
balance people or institutions hide
themselves in positions where they have
to try for trust from different sites
such as a university is trying for trust
from parents who are sending their kids
there as well as from the kids now
sometimes it may sometimes it may not be
contradicting things that you would feel
you should act like to gain the trust of
these sites so you have to obtain a
balance to gain trust from both sides
can you comment or give an example how
caltac is stealing visitors you and
keeping the balance I mean in the sense
of reassuring the parents that the kids
are taken care of and their welfare is
assured and assuring the kids that they
have room to grow that hey they have
room to and fold themselves you've hit
on one of the stickiest problems that we
have in Caltech probably that all
institutions have and that we're just
now trying to figure out how to deal
with how do you I'll put a different way
how do you allow students to have
autonomy in the pursuit of of their
education and at the same time guarantee
both their safety and their growth as
individuals and it's it's a delicate
balance we in the United States for
instance generally have students in most
universities in some kind of a dormitory
housing situation particularly as
freshmen and I know that at MIT is going
to house all of its freshmen in
dormitories
abroad people go to college and they
live in apartments and they don't live
in controlled circumstance they make all
their own decisions so there are various
sorts of models of how you take the
responsibility that's being handed to
you by people sending their children
children to college and all I can say is
that I'm trying to wrestle with that
balance today myself and I don't know
where it sits but I do know it's a
changing framework that societal
framework that we're living with changed
enormous lis from the time when I was in
college and all of our activities were
second-guessed but I don't think we've
found the right the right mix and
particularly with the potentially
self-destructive things that are
available in our society today drugs and
alcohol being the two major ones it's
very difficult to know where to put
strike that balance so another question
I haven't answered you use the word
trust to cover everything from someone
possibly being dishonest to not checking
calculations enough
that's goes sort of beyond what I would
you know III would say you know belief
might might come into that or you could
use trust but it's sort of the meaning
of it kind of spreads out in different
directions
and but what what really made me wonder
was your you said that decisions would
in the next ten years be greatly better
understood by study of the brain now if
you are trying to appoint someone to a
job say where you have all different
kinds of trusts in them from moral to
believing they have talent to believing
they have a certain call
is a character that will do the job well
it's such a tremendously complex thing
how can you read things from the state
of the brain that are really going to
get you to the heart of that
particularly considering that if if I am
looking into your brain and deciding
that you've made a decision because you
have certain attitudes about things
outside yourself the state of the world
the state of another person I have to
judge whether you're right as well so it
seems like there's a gap there and what
can be understood by studying the brain
I think we're mixing up two things I was
suggesting that by studying the brain we
could begin to understand the the
concepts that are involved in
interpersonal relations and how those
are translated into actual brain
activity which is what we can measure
today we'll measure more than that in
the future I wasn't suggesting that we
use that as a diagnostic tool to figure
out whether an individual is trustworthy
or not I suppose it might come to that
but I really hadn't even thought of that
and was certainly not suggesting that
that's the direction we're going in I
was talking talking much more about how
you scientifically investigate the the
elusive concepts of social science I
think we should thank professor
Baltimore once more and there's a
reception out in the lobby
you